who is the agent the one who's
responsible yeah because he made the
[ __ ] Charlotte sure he got breathing
before you got a feeling ten days before
you go for the monkey you know exactly
you just can't stick your hand the
monkey out of trunk expect to get some
way
uncle Joey an acupuncture needle
sticking out of my ear I got one coming
out of my hand over here you see ya show
these savages
hi everybody dr. Amy here we go
and it's a little red kissy head cupping
you guys know about cupping you probably
do everybody does
since Michael Phelps right can I keep
telling them Joey clogged in the ear I
don't know if they can see everything
should I show them the dog
sure sure stop licking yourself and say
hi to Joey's peeps the cupping area one
the things you put the needles homegoing
how do I get my [ __ ] together uncle Joey
you got to do some acupuncture and then
later on I stick a needle in my nut sack
and that gets everything going the heart
the lungs the whole thing will be a
hang-up with dr. Amy trying to get my
life together people it's lunchtime
no jujitsu today little acupuncture
Marina del Rey if you need acupuncture
it called dr. Amy Freedman what's the
number dr. demian know what's the
website
fleet men acupuncture in Marina del Rey
she'll change a goddamn life you
understand me
stay black [ __ ] my peeps stay
beautiful